Son las 4 a.m. y en 8 horas
tienes un examen importante,
seguido por un recital de piano.
Has estudiado y practicado durante días,
pero todavía no te sientes preparado.
Entonces, ¿qué puedes hacer?
Bueno, puedes beber
otra taza de café
y pasar las próximas horas
estudiando y practicando,
pero, aunque no lo creas,
puede que sea mejor que cierres
los libros, guardes el piano
y vayas a dormir.
Dormir ocupa casi un tercio
de nuestras vidas,
pero, sorprendentemente, muchos
le prestamos poca atención.
Este descuido es, muchas veces,
resultado de un gran malentendido.
Dormir no es perder el tiempo,
o solo una manera de descansar
cuando nuestro trabajo está terminado.
El sueño es una función crucial
en la que tu cuerpo equilibra y monitorea
sus sistemas vitales; eso afecta
tu respiración y la regulación
de todo, desde la circulación hasta
el crecimiento y la respuesta inmunitaria.
Eso es fantástico, pero puedes preocuparte
por esas cosas luego del examen, ¿no?
Bueno, no tan rápido.
Resulta que el sueño también
es crucial para el cerebro,
ya que un quinto de
la sangre del cuerpo
se dirige hacia allí
mientras duermes.
Y el momento en el que duermes
es un período de reestructuración
intensamente activo,
fundamental para el
funcionamiento de la memoria.
A primera vista,
nuestra capacidad de recordar cosas
no parece muy impresionante.
Herman Ebbinghaus, un psicólogo
del siglo XIX,
demostró que normalmente olvidamos
el 40 % de lo que aprendemos
dentro de los primeros 20 minutos,
un fenómeno conocido como
la curva del olvido.
Pero esta pérdida puede prevenirse
con la consolidación de la memoria,
el proceso por el cual
la información se mueve
de la breve memoria de corto plazo
a la más duradera memoria de largo plazo.
Esta consolidación ocurre gracias
a una parte importante del cerebro
conocida como hipocampo.
Su función en la formación
de la memoria a largo plazo fue demostrada
en los años 50 por Brenda Milner
en sus estudios de un paciente
conocido como H.M.
Luego de que le quitaran el hipocampo,
la capacidad de H.M. para formar nuevos
recuerdos a corto plazo se vio dañada,
pero podía aprender tareas físicas
mediante la repetición.
Debido a la extracción del hipocampo,
la habilidad de H.M. para formar recuerdos
a largo plazo también se vio dañada.
Este caso reveló,
entre otras cosas,
que el hipocampo estaba
específicamente involucrado
en la consolidación de la memoria
declarativa a largo plazo,
necesaria para recordar datos
y conceptos para tu examen,
más que en la memoria procedimental,
que incluye los movimientos de los dedos
que necesitas dominar para el recital.
Los hallazgos de Milner, sumados
al trabajo de Eric Kandel en los años 90,
nos dieron el modelo actual de funcionamiento
de este proceso de consolidación.
La información sensorial es transcripta
y almacenada temporalmente en las neuronas
como memoria a corto plazo.
Desde allí, viaja al hipocampo,
que fortalece y mejora
las neuronas en esa área.
Gracias a la neuroplasticidad,
se forman nuevas sinapsis, lo que permite
nuevas conexiones entre las neuronas
y fortalece la red neuronal
a donde la información volverá
como memoria a largo plazo.
Entonces, ¿por qué recordamos
algunas cosas y no otras?
Hay algunas formas de influenciar
el alcance y la eficacia
de la retención de recuerdos.
Por ejemplo, los recuerdos creados
en momentos de emociones intensas,
o incluso estrés,
serán registrados mejor, dada la relación
del hipocampo con las emociones.
Pero uno de los grandes factores que
ayudan a la consolidación de la memoria es,
lo adivinaste,
dormir bien por la noche.
El sueño está compuesto por 4 fases.
Las más profundas son conocidas
como sueño de ondas lentas
y sueño de movimientos
oculares rápidos (MOR).
Los electroencefalogramas realizados
a personas durante estas fases
han mostrado impulsos eléctricos
entre el tronco encefálico, el hipocampo,
el tálamo y la corteza cerebral,
que funcionan como estaciones repetidoras
en la formación de recuerdos.
Se ha demostrado que las diferentes fases
del sueño ayudan a consolidar
distintos tipos de memorias.
Durante la fase de sueño de ondas lentas
se codifica la memoria declarativa
de forma provisional
en la parte frontal del hipocampo.
A través de un diálogo continuo
entre la corteza y el hipocampo,
es reactivada de forma reiterada
hasta ser distribuida en donde será
almacenada a largo plazo en la corteza.
El sueño MOR, similar a la actividad
cerebral de alguien despierto,
es asociado con la consolidación
de la memoria procedimental.
Entonces, de acuerdo con los estudios,
acostarte 3 horas luego
de memorizar tus fórmulas
y una hora luego de practicar
tus escalas sería lo ideal.
Con suerte, ahora podrás ver
que escatimar en sueño
no solo daña tu salud a largo plazo,
sino que hace que sea menos probable
que retengas todo ese conocimiento
y práctica de la noche anterior.
Todo esto reafirma el dicho
"consultarlo con la almohada".
Si piensas en el
reestructuramiento interno
y las nuevas conexiones que se forman
mientras duermes, podrías hasta decir
que una buena noche de sueño
hará que te despiertes cada mañana
con un nuevo y mejorado cerebro,
listo para enfrentar
los desafíos del día.